how are you both doing
good we're good good to see you
nice to see you um i like throwing a
curveball at the beginning if you could
get the financing to make anything you
want what would you make and why
oh wow
um you know what um there's i i grew up
with british uh children's literature i
didn't grow up with uh
marvel or dc so much and there's a
british author called raymond briggs who
wrote amazing graphic novels one of
them's called fungus the bogeyman i
would love to make an animated version
of that super weird but awesome
i guess for me it's just telling even
though we're having like such a big
budget it would be just to tell like a
afro-latino story and be able to set it
in
somewhere out in the caribbean so that
to me would be awesome
i like both of these ideas
uh animation obviously technology is a
huge part of making any animated movie
what um i guess my question is what how
is technology the last few years or just
recently helped to tell this story
well it's uh enabled us to make a movie
during a global pandemic
for once um
we did not know when we started telling
this story about tech uh that it was
actually gonna start to become even more
relevant uh the more we made it we were
actually terrified that our story was
going to get out of date uh because
animation takes so long to make right so
uh we were wondering maybe in three
years time you know social networks will
look different but in actual fact i
think especially through the pandemic
and spending more time online this kind
of question of
what does it how does it affect us has
become even more kind of relevant
really um one of the things that uh um
did you i like talking about other
possible titles so ron's gone wrong did
you have another idea that almost became
the title
um
we we had lots of arguments about the
title for sure um it was a hard one to
figure out
ron's gone wrong was one that uh disney
loved in fact we were just we were
thinking about calling it just ron or
ron with the with a zero um
uh
we have we have a very feisty creative
team so plenty of arguments but it
always kind of had ron in the name so
that's where we started
uh animated movies change a lot during
development i've spoken to so many
directors who've talked about how
radically it can shift i'm curious with
this from when you first started to what
people see on screen did this how
radical of a change did this movie go
through or was it pretty much what you
guys envisioned when you first started
it was pretty much what um was pitched
away a while back and and that's one of
the things that was just always
attractive because it had such a genuine
and heart story with a lot of comedy and
it just worked so a lot of it was just
trying to be
honest and and continually have that
connection of what the core idea of what
we believed in for the story to be
uh easter eggs i'm sure you planted a
few um do you want to or maybe you
didn't uh are there easter eggs that
fans should be looking out for
well there's a lot of bots that have
some really cool skins that we've dotted
around uh so uh some amazing marvel
characters um some star wars characters
in there uh my personal favorite is a
tribute to a certain post-apocalyptic
anime movie
so uh so fans can take a look uh see if
they can find that
well that actually is my a follow-up
that i had which is was it tough to
actually get star wars and some of these
other things or once uh fox joined
disney it was like yeah whatever you
want to do
well oh yeah sorry no no it's okay uh
i think for us was like trying to see
because we had so many different kids
with so many different ideas and um and
just
you know likes of what they would want
and personalize the bots with the skins
um we were hoping and again it was about
story trying to get it you know to uh
and to convince them it wasn't that much
to convince because of what we were
trying to do
yeah i mean um once we were in disney's
hands it was really about um them
getting to know our movie uh and then
getting to love it and then giving
permission for for us to have those
characters which was uh we're really
grateful it was awesome to be able to do
that
yeah i can only imagine what it was like
getting that email or call uh when
you're allowed when you find out you're
allowed to use star wars and other
things
oh yeah awesome and once we had those
stormtrooper bots in a line we were like
oh my gosh
we did it
no it's it's that's great um the movie
one of the things i think the film does
very well is that many things but the
movie deals with like how what kids are
going through in the social media age
and can you sort of talk about that
because it's really impacting everyone
across the entire globe
yeah i think the the most pertinent
thing is that
it's really potentially putting more
pressure on the way we see ourselves
right because it's kind of like there's
all these metrics about how many people
follow you how many people like you uh
and
that's one thing that i think especially
as parents we're really
thinking a lot about right like what's
it like for our children growing up with
all this extra pressure we didn't have
that and yet we still had issues with
insecurity with loneliness or with
feeling like we can't find our tribe
all right and uh that is what we wanted
to personify in our main character
barney he already feels that but even
more so now because all these bee bots
are in the world kind of advertising
everyone's coolness and popularity and
all he wants is a bee bot to help him
and he's going to get a broken one so
now great he's
he's this outsider kid with a
dysfunctional robot
and that's kind of like the comedy
starting point that we wanted to explore
you know this sense of it's okay to have
a relationship that is based on
messiness it's a two-way street it's
about knowing the things that you
wouldn't share online that are things
that are real about you things that
you're you're scared about and insecure
about that's actually what makes a real
uh thriving friendship
one of the other things about this film
is that it doesn't make the
listen technology's not going away and
the fact is that if somebody invented a
bee bot it's never gonna i mean that's
just too much money on the line and it
doesn't i like how the film doesn't just
pretend they're all gonna go away and
you know everything's going to go back
to the way it was can you sort of talk
about that the technology is here to
stay good or bad yes and that's
something i mean it's a great point
that's one of the things that we wanted
to embrace uh the technology and not
criticize it being bad or good it's just
a sense of like how do we continue to be
connected um as just as human beings
making being what's a true friendship
and that idea of that of what it takes
to be stay connected
yeah we know that you know no one's no
one's getting rid of their phones
so in our story we had to kind of find a
way to like okay how can ron influence
it all uh in a completely brand new way
they still get the experience of being
connected with new people with their bee
bots
uh one of the things that must be tough
for animation is to uh are jokes i've
spoken other directors about this
because you insert a joke then you're
watching it about a thousand times it's
no longer funny and how can you sort of
talk about the fact that well how tough
it is to do jokes and animation and make
sh and not take them out because you
think they're no longer funny
it's really hard because we're in a
five-year timeline sometimes making this
movie um
you know there is like the universal uh
sense that a joke is landing
because it's almost like a drum beat
like the rhythm is hitting uh there's a
lot of visual comedy in this uh in this
movie and it's so much about sound
design and rhythm
and placement of specific ideas uh but
as you say we can get super blind to
whether they're funny or not and that to
that end we have to screen it and get
honest feedback uh and uh if the
feedback's good it stays in
uh this was locksmith animations i
believe first feature film uh
um so can you sort of talk about the
fact that it is their first feature what
did you enjoy about working with them
what'd you learn
yeah uh this is our first feature but we
had such an amazing talent that we
brought together and that is again for
you know julie um sarah and liz bringing
all this great talent um was just so
fortunate for us starting out um and
having this experience of working with
um all these amazing artists and
collaboration from animation to layout
to editorial um we were just in a good
spot to be able to explore things within
our story and in the film
yeah the animation look oh sorry
no i was going to say it's super
exciting to work at a startup again you
know
we came you know we worked at pixar
together and it was an invaluable
experience but there's something really
special about trying to trying to hit
the same storytelling peaks
but doing it um with a startup um and in
the uk there's such an amazing
talent base as well so it's it's
personally really exciting for for that
to be happening right here
i thought the animation looked really
cool um i got to stop thank you guys so
much for your time hope the film's a
huge hit all right thank you
thank you
you